hey guys i'm starting to think
maybe the supreme court was a good
enough reason to vote
for hillary clinton after all they've
done it
donald trump's supreme court nominee to
replace ruth bader ginsburg
has been confirmed by the senate
and sworn in at a very trashy event last
night
at the white house amy coney barrett is
in
and it is over republicans during barack
obama's
presidency saying we don't confirm
supreme court justices in the last year
of a presidency
and with seven last night just shy
of a week or just beyond one week to go
before
a presidential election confirming and
swearing
in a supreme court justice and amy coney
barrett will now be on the court
to rule over any possible
election-related matters and there very
well may be some which we will
be talking about this week so not coming
as an acute surprise in the sense that
we determined weeks ago
there was no way for democrats to
prevent this from happening and indeed
they did not prevent this from happening
and she is now on the court they
won gotta hand it to him mitch mcconnell
gleeful on fox news last night and this
is how it works sadly they stopped
barack obama's nominee merrick garland
because they controlled the senate they
stopped it with garbage arguments which
they immediately
threw into the trash and now under
donald trump
because they control the senate trump
has confirmed
three supreme court justices and we have
a
6 to three majority against
the better judgment of doctors
everywhere the trump administration put
together a white house event
to swear in amy coney barrett last night
melania trump who still had coronavirus
symptoms
serious enough for her to miss attending
a trump rally
just days ago uh showing up with no mask
at this event right near a whole bunch
of people here is trump making no sense
whatsoever and they came
completely nonsensical run on sentence
we are fulfilling
the duty that passes to each new
generation to sustain
the national traditions and virtues that
make possible
everything we have achieved before that
we will do tomorrow because of
our just unintelligible
and then eventually the swearing in
itself taking place
with clarence thomas happening naturally
without masks
or social distancing clarence thomas at
one point whispering
into the ear of amy coney barrett in
close proximity as donald trump
looks on here is mitch mcconnell the
republican senate majority leader
straight up saying amy coney barrett
will be a political asset wait
but but but but i thought that these
justices
simply interpreted the law and applied
it to
no no no she's going to be a political
asset says mitch mcconnell voting for
biden
well if you recall we had a supreme
court fight a month before the election
in 2018 and we actually gain seats
i think this nominee will be a political
asset
for our candidates around the country
not a liability but an asset
that's a supreme court justice he's
talking about
as a political asset not an interpreter
of the law
not a mere conduit through which the
constitution
and case law flow and spit out like a
machine
some kind of decision no no they're not
even hiding it a political
asset and then here is lindsey graham
who is in a very tough race in south
carolina saying
amy coney barrett will help us to
keep our seats we're in a fight for our
life
help me help all of us keep our seats
so we can do this four more years
lindsey graham.com
lindsey graham republican senator from
south carolina
in a really tough situation all of a
sudden against the democratic challenger
jamie harrison
says amy coney barrett might help him
to keep his seat they aren't even
pretending now we have to really
understand a lot of different
things here there were leftists who
missed the boat in 2016.
okay they said it's not whoever
trump hillary it's all the same supreme
court
who cares it's not important well
we not we learned that that was the
wrong approach we now have
three lunatics on the supreme court
and you could say hillary clinton
wouldn't have put a real
progressive on the court uh but she
wasn't going to put on
religious nut ideologues and cuckoo for
coco puffs jurists
uh she wouldn't have done it okay we
would be in f
we wouldn't be talking about is abortion
in danger
is gay marriage in danger is religious
liberty as it is
actually supposed to exist in danger
because remember
their their view of religious liberty is
the freedom of religion to impose my
religion on others that's not freedom of
religion
it is now all in danger it wouldn't be
had hillary clinton won well
we now have the 2020 election um the
2020 election unfortunately
is now going to be subject to
this court thanks to donald trump
putting three people
on it so we have a six to three majority
for the right
we all have to understand i mean listen
at no point am i going to
gaslight you just replacing trump with
biden doesn't fix the court
it's too late okay we blew it
we blew it this is the court until
another justice leaves so
now we need to remove trump and vote
biden
merely to have a chance to move the
court from six
three to five four and then if we get it
to five four to reverse it to a five
four
left majority or maybe expand the court
now we'll be talking more about court
expansion
i i will tell you i am more in favor
today of expanding the court than i have
ever been
there are still political risks we're
going to talk about it i don't think joe
biden's going to do it
unless he really really is pushed uh so
this is a loss for us they want it we
have to deal with it as it is not as we
would like it to be
we have seven days until we can replace
trump with biden that will prevent trump
from putting anyone else on the court
for four years
so that is a win although it doesn't
resolve the situation and then lastly
the cherry on top
mitch mcconnell has adjourned the senate
until november 9th
putting in a supreme court justice in
direct
contravention to the principles he said
apply
during the last year of a presidential
term in 2016
and then immediately adjourning the
senate meaning
no coronavirus stimulus
even possible before the election
they won't even reconvene until november
9th
unbelievable this is the guy this is the
guy that's running the senate
we've got to end it guys it it must be
stopped
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within 100 days if you don't
love it
but i think you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video